un povero ragazzo sperduto nel deserto
lasciato solo abbandonato alla sorte
vagava e vagava per chilometri in cerca
della civiltà ma nonostante i suoi
sforzi non riusciva a trovare nulla
nessuna forma di vita nessuno che lo
aiutasse povero ragazzo comincia a
realizzare che l'unica via d'uscita
tutto questo sarebbe stata la morte
soltanto una cosa avrebbe potuto
salvarlo da questi intemperie una forma
di vita non umana che avrebbe potuto
chiamare i soccorsi per lui se soltanto
che fosse riuscito a convincerla a farlo
quindi ragazzi state per assistere alla
richiesta d'aiuto più sensazionale della
storia siete pronti via
no no no cnac un cazzo koch noti ragazzi
e benvenuto questo video sono famigliari
[ __ ] deserto di merda è l'unica cazzo
di cosa con cui posso parlare da giorni
e vi è stat rai ascolta zia knock knock
un cazzo proprio è capito che mi prende
per il culo ragazzo e non ha senso
ascoltati a sono perso nel deserto è
l'unica [ __ ] forma di vita con la
quale posso parlare sei tu hai capito
guarda che cinque minuti fa ieri maschio
che cazzo c'entra cielo ancora al bene
guarda che sono ancora maschio sono solo
perso ecco qui a parlare con questa qui
e allora madona gli schiaffi in faccia e
allora perditi cicchitto nel deserto non
io
bird bird ma perché tu stai mese bene
che ascolti one direzione sentiti
ascolto quello che cazzo voglio che
sulla statale quando election ascolti
one direction nomi dei cag aree cazzo ok
cosa c'è in quello sguardo contro james
ma lo sai che si è perso nel
deserto veramente non lo sapevo lo
sapevo lo dico io ma l'ho visto prima
ascoltami siccome siamo tutti e due
persi cosa facciamo
tua madre un robot io col cazzo cosa
possiamo fare insieme di melo come
possiamo salvare siamo persi non egizio
tu sei cosa possiamo fare insieme
note lo sto chiedendo io [ __ ] cosa cosa
dimmelo dimmelo come mondo sa affanculo
6 utile quanto una suora in un bordello
anche tu piccola cosa ma come dobbiamo
metterci in salvo lo capisci trans
riuscirà in qualche modo io mi chiamo
lorenzo ostuni primo vent'anni secondo e
terzo non vengono a napoli ma da torino
ma che cazzo c'entra come tese uscita
questa frase veramente si scrive lorenzo
ostuni ti sei sbagliata manco il mio
nome manco scrivi no vabbè allora mi
chiamerò così da cimatti lorenzo studi
per prendevo sempre quattro però conosci
park j
certo la madonna grazie a michele
gentile cosa ti piace di lui come i
cantoni come canzone faccio una canzone
gliela do allora cosa ti canto qualche
canzone del deserto magari non lo so
sono umano sono umano non la conosco le
inventiamo sono mano anch'io come
sono come sta succedendo a farti [ __ ]
senti abbiamo bisogno di rinforzi chiama
qualcuno li ami
ma che cosa me ne frega adesso certo che
ti amo ma quindi possiamo fare cose
sporche fai come ti paga bene basta
dirlo senti pensiamo dopo alle cose
sporche
ora dobbiamo scappare aiuto domani
pomeriggio sono libere
che cosa vado a domani pomeriggio calci
in culo tu non sei qui con me chiama la
polizia aiutami cazzo nokia ma non posso
solo nel deserto madonna non prende una
sega prendono le rocce non posso sono
nel deserto e di chiamarla e dire loro
che sono disperso allora non ti voglio
parlare io legano se tornassi mai la
civita l'ammazzo l'ammazzo senti ascolta
capiscimi [ __ ] devi chiamare aiuto per
me capito
madonna è impossibile ok ok amari ora
nulla ma che problemi hai io nessuno e
allora cosa non capisci della parola
aiuto cazzo e h m e sa come lo chiamiamo
il nostro figlio
ma perché non lo chiamiamo ciò la mamma
[ __ ] non so mi viene così è lo
chiamiamo alfredo menico ti piace magari
se la ii in questi discorsi mi aiutano
soci skiff del nero ma non è così
schifoso come nome dai apprezzabile a
parte
nostro figlio che frega cazzi miei
aiuteresti per favore non su il nostro
chiamiamolo nostromo lui voglio morire
no non mi salvare più voglio morire
adesso cioè ragazzi non è 8 tanto people
beni che cazzo dici non si capisce
quello che dici parla bene almeno se
devo morire con una che mi parla bene
nemmeno quello che dici tu sei per
questo come ma che cazzo io scrivo
benissimo forse non benissimo che
quello quello deve essere quello che ha
detto di no senti non chiamiamo aiuto
dimmi solo secondo te cosa posso fare
per salvarmi un ottima come facciamo ad
incontrarci arin contattarci
non possiamo perché sono nel deserto e
nel deserto non so se lo sai non c'è un
cazzo ok non due uomini non puoi amarmi
non ti amo non esiste questa mohr keet
tu sei solo turini manuri ci mancherebbe
che cosa voleva che mi rispondesse cioè
spiegami perchè cazzo mi chiami amore se
poi nel deserto che a [ __ ] sono
cascate le mie figurini faccia piace
questa e questa è bella
vedi quanto sono figo zia amore
ascoltami queste potrebbero essere le
mie ultime parole io ti amo e ti ho
sempre amato sempre più ai buoni uccider
novo yo yo [ __ ] muoio io no tesoro
non ti farei mai del male
sono io che muoio neanche io ti farei
mai del male davvero
e allora perché non chiami questi cazzo
di soccorse perchè vorrei essere la tua
fidanzata non puoi se muoio strozza via
ma la pole a hockey amore sei bellissima
di mattino quando ti svegli comodo basta
il suicidio ma mai phishing chi sente
devo provare a scappare
io ti saluto ciao chiara loro ciao ciao
prefetto ragazzi chiudo qua bella a
tutti i ragazzi voglio vedere se lo vedo
mi risponde giusto per curiosità per
chiudo perché non ce la faccio più non
per i fini ma e miele nuovo the verge
grazie benigni e mina video li trovavi
jb ha bisogno perché credo servito più
strano che io abbia mai fatto nella mia
vita prova da vedere se le scatole alla
civiltà ma ne dubito è se vedete questo
video chiamati i soccorsi
ti prego certo è colonna sul telecomando
che scrivo con le figurine e si apre
questa merda però che faccio ciò non
riesco no ce n'è un altro se non altro
chi ci sono io che sono piccolo ci posso
fare se l'avessi di scrittrici
diventavano prossimo vito per ragazzi